lava has bubbled from Ethiopia Sirte
Allah volcano non-stop for almost a
century at temperatures more than 2,000
degrees Fahrenheit now an unlikely team
of explorers is headed to the volcano
leading the trip our Franck Tessier and
Irene margaritas professors at the
University of nice their passion is
volcanoes
they're joined by guess ahangar goo a
volcanologist at Addis Ababa University
he's keen to collect lava samples from
inside the volcano something no-one's
done in almost a quarter of a century
far below in the black heart of the
crater is the lava lake called the
hellhole of creation the afar triangle
lies at the junction of three
continental plates which spread further
each year possibly the oldest living
lava lake and one of the lowest points
on the planet geologists here can study
the processes that form the world
millions of years ago now it's time for
the team to get to work if they are to
climb down into this cauldron they must
first rig lifelines
from the middle Franck lowers himself to
the crater floor
some situations are very difficult to
negotiate it's impossible to alter zero
risk once both Frank and Irene have
reached the crater floor the real work
begins getting lava out of a boiling pit
is no easy task
Franck tosses a cable into the pit
hoping the lava will cake to it he tries
again and again even in the darkness he
can't get close enough at every attempt
the heat drives him back so he calls
trip photographer Carsten Peter to bring
him a thermal suit it is France only
hope to get close enough to the red-hot
magma
over and over froth throws a cable into
the pit but each time the lava quickly
melts the cable
in the end Franck is forced to collect
samples line at the edge of the lava pit
it's 2:00 a.m. before they return
exhausted to the surface gesehen eagerly
bags and indexes the samples keen to get
them back to addis ababa in this barren
lifeless place he hopes they have
discovered new secrets of earth to
'allah volcano not only how this
incredible inferno was formed and how
old it is but also about the formation
of the world itself